he's not just a member of the senate
he's the senate majority leader
and he still can't get it done if she
goes to washington
the first vote she'll cast in the senate
is to make chuck schumer from new york
the majority leader when we think about
the fact that susan collins
has voted to undermine or repeal the
affordable care act
multiple times we need to know that
we're electing a senator who is going to
fight to protect and expand our health
care
the amount of money coming into these
races including into texas that we've
never seen before
is really kind of making things a little
more questionable than they would
otherwise be
18 days big obviously presidential
election we're following it closely but
all of these senate races
very important with the control of the
united states senate
hanging in the balance we're back with
our panel asked each panelist to pick a
senate race
they're following jeff let's start with
you sure
the one that i'm following is in
michigan one that i
i don't think has been on a lot of
people's radars uh vice president biden
was campaigning there today
and included a shout out for senator
gary peters who is
has been leading in that race but
republican john james has been
gaining on him in according to recent
polls so if the republican were able to
uh win over that seat that could keep or
help keep
the control of the senate in republican
hands
yeah and if the recent poll that the
president touted
is right that he has closed the gap in
michigan
that obviously makes a big difference in
that race kimberly your choice sure
so i've been looking at south carolina
and the all-powerful
judiciary chairman head lindsey graham
mostly because i think this is somewhat
representative of what we've been
talking about some changes we're seeing
in the polls i remember three or four
weeks ago
all the headlines were about just how
bad it was for every republican
candidate so bad that
they were worried about texas and
kentucky mitch mcconnell and
lindsey graham but what you're seeing in
these final weeks is because of some
good issues republicans have and had
in particular this supreme court hearing
which mr
graham has really capitalized on you see
some republican
on the fence voters coming home and you
see those polls tightening to the extent
that
some of those races now seem to be
pretty much in hand for republicans
all right jonah what are you looking at
um i'm looking at the
georgia senate race with senator perdue
versus john ossoff
i will admit one of the reasons why i'm
looking at this is because
i'm lazy and like to go to bed early and
on election night
i think this is a real bellwether to
tell whether the republicans are going
to hold on to the senate
right now it's a toss-up with purdue
with a one-point
uh advantage basically a statistical tie
john ossoff
is very much a a very woke dem
liberal democrat and if he actually
topples purdue
that is a bad sign for the republicans
overall
in a state like georgia okay let's go
around the horn winners and losers jeff
you're first winner than loser
so i picked amy coney barrett as the
winner for this week for unflappable
testimony during
the supreme court hearings and for the
losers i've went with airlines and other
companies that are
hoping for some stimulus help from the
congress
may still happen but not happening
nearly as quickly as they were
as they were hoping yeah so as we were
saying the negotiations continuing
tomorrow night apparently between the
treasury secretary and the house
speaker ari kimberly your next winner
and loser
so my winner is actually laura woke who
was a supreme court's first blind law
clerk
amy coney barrett was her teacher and
she gave the most eloquent
um appraisal and and and recommendation
of amy coney barrett this week it was
something to watch
um my loser was nancy pelosi and her
meltdown with wolf blitzer this week
an indication of how democrats too often
react when they're asked
simple questions all right uh jonah
winner and loser so my winner is the
satirical site babylon b
one of the funniest sites on the web uh
because donald trump did them a huge
favor of tweeting them as if they were
serious news
uh just this morning and not since the
judge in miracle on 34th street declared
the existence of santa
was a greater gift given to a satire
site um
on the loser side i'm sad to say this
because he's a very nice guy but steve
scully of c-span
i don't think we've seen a more unforced
error
um in uh washington politics in a long
time where he claimed he was hacked and
he wasn't
and um it's sad to see the hit to a guy
who was very well respected around here
all right panel thank you very much